seven days ago today i did a video and i
talked about my opinion on the world
economic forum i showed how prince
charles was one of the founding members
of the world economic forum how their
global elitist movement was that we
would own nothing and be happy about it
meanwhile they own everything and this
video has had over half a million views
on youtube in the last seven days and i
announced on twitter that i would get
consequences as a result of this in the
last week a lot has happened i've been
hit personally in my opinion by members
of the world economic forum and i'm
going to share and you can make up your
own mind as to what you think because
you know they're talking about it's a
conspiracy even in the media now they're
saying oh it's conspiracy all these
things the great reset is a conspiracy
no that's the name that they gave it you
know and also conspiracy what is a
conspiracy if someone's talking about me
and they're coming up with theories i
don't call it a conspiracy theory do you
know that they came up with the name
conspiracy theory just to discredit
theories
so look do your research so since last
week a lot's happened number one the
queen has sadly passed away and now
prince charles is the king which is
quite scary as he's one of the founding
members of the world economic forum liz
truss has become prime minister
and she's also a member of the world
economic forum and i'm being hit by the
media who are members of the world
economic forum this is very interesting
isn't it let me tell you what happened a
lot of people are asking me what do i
think about liz trust and how is it
going to affect property investors my
true opinion is same agenda just a
different puppet when people change
their minds their political stance when
their whole value system just suddenly
can change overnight
i think that shows that they're probably
just a puppet i mean if you look at some
of the stuff joe biden was saying 10 20
years ago it's absolutely different to
what he's saying today why do we need a
constitutional amendment marriage is
between a man and a woman what's the
game going on here
liz trust was part of the lib dem
movement and then suddenly just changes
to conservative so i genuinely i'm not
too sure what i think about her as a
person but i do think that she's in
position of power but she's probably
being controlled by higher powers just a
matter of days after publishing the
video and after received half a million
views on youtube suddenly
bang an article drops by the guardian
and it's a very strange article it says
property investor accused of shutting
down criticism over ten thousand pound
courses i think actually i don't think
i'm the one here that shutting down any
criticism at all i mean yes it's true
that i was trolled and harassed in 2019
2020 and i had to take legal action and
as a result of that there were people
that got prosecuted there were people
ryan james turner has now got a criminal
record he's got 180 hours of community
service andrew dunn had to compensate me
financially so i think that's me just
protecting my family protecting my staff
after receiving death threats and my
wife getting racial messages so i don't
think that's anything particularly
interesting to write about but they've
tried to spin the story the guardian
have as if i'm some sort of big rich
bully boy company that's shutting people
down which i think is quite ironic what
i also think is interesting is if you
look at who owns the guardian the
guardian is owned by the scot trust i
thought this is very interesting let's
have a little look at what the scot
trust actually do and it's very vague
and ambiguous so in the end i thought
well let's just follow the money and see
who owns the scott trust and very
interestingly it comes up with apax
partners now i have no idea who apex
partners is but i thought maybe by sheer
coincidence there's something to do with
the world economic forum so i searched
apac partners in the world economic
forum and bang they are partners with
the world economic forum now i'm not
saying that the world economic forum and
apex partners have pulled the strings to
try and discredit me and it's all come
as a as a result of that video i did
last week but isn't it a little bit of a
coincidence the thing is if they had
deleted the video if youtube had
deleted the video what would have
happened is the thousands of people in
the comments would have realized that
the video was deleted for a reason it
would have made a martyr out of me so
instead of trying to de-platform me what
they did instead was try to discredit me
in the media but unfortunately for them
they really haven't got much to say
apart from that i have sued and are
suing people and yes that is correct i
absolutely am i spoke many years ago
about the agenda being that we will have
a cashless society and this is something
that is coming into fruition right now
as we speak my prediction is that in
five years time there will be no more
cash because if we pay for things in
cash then we have control i can do
business with you without them being
involved but if everything is cashless
and we are in the cash to society then
ultimately if they don't like the
business that they're doing they can
stop it and they can control it any
given moment the agenda is to stop us
owning property so bill gates who's
associated with the world economic forum
owns more farmland than anybody else in
the world bill gates is buying so much
farmland right now yet the world
economic forum is saying that we should
own nothing and be happy about it after
the queen's passing and liz trust being
put as the prime minister and king
charles who is one of the founding
members of the world economic forum
becoming king interesting that they
suddenly changed the rules in property
quite a lot they're changing the
legislation in property here in the uk
as we speak during all the distraction
of everything that's going on they're
scrapping tenant eviction section 21
bans which is meaning it's very
difficult now to become a landlord
they've officially frozen rents now in
scotland and sadiq khan is pushing to do
the same in london i think we need a
mere fire to run control in london of
course what the rich do is they find
ways around it so for instance service
accommodation if you've got guests and
they're staying as a guest in your
airbnb property they have zero rights
ironically that's what the queen
recently did it was reported that she
was renting out sandringham house on
airbnb while they're trying to stop us
owning land and properties i'm here in
the uk helping more people become
property owners landowners and property
investors than any other property
trainer or investor out there in the
whole of europe and thirdly they're
trying to make us compliant the media
tells us how to think and anybody who
thinks differently is alienated anybody
who speaks out is either discredited or
deplatformed while prince andrew was
being wrapped up in sex trafficking and
underage children princess diana was
beginning to speak out he got 12 million
pounds and she got epstein who was
friends with prince andrew got locked up
and he no longer had any reason to hide
anything so he killed himself
conspiracies or logical conclusions i'm
not saying this is factual i'm saying
that this is a logical conclusion as to
what possibly happened but even though
i'm just asking questions and trying to
challenge the status quo even though i
want the rich and poor divide to get
smaller while they're trying to make it
bigger no doubt i will continue to be
hounded by the media you will see more
discrediting negative media articles
written about me and just for the record
i would never kill myself